this video is sponsored by Skillshare
use the link in the description to watch
my class and thousands of others with a
free two-month trial visiting Japan
feels a bit like taking a trip to the
future robots serve and deliver your
food vending machines sell everything
from umbrellas to puppies
bullet trains whisk you around the
island at 320 kilometres an hour and
it's median age of 47 point 3 the second
highest in the world warns of the global
aging soon to come there's one way
however where Japan is stuck in the past
walking around Tokyo or Osaka or ko Bay
you might notice something odd a
strangely high number of music stores
compared to the US Japan has 40% as many
people but nearly double the number of
music shops as a whole the Japanese
music market is the second biggest in
the world but unlike almost any other in
most parts of the world streaming has
replaced physical sales in 2015 for
example 66 percent of US music sales
were digital in Japan it's nearly the
opposite 75 percent of sales or physical
and only 18 percent or digital this is
due in part to the country's stringent
copyright laws licensing restrictions
and rental culture but there's another
reason CDs are still loved in countries
like Japan and South Korea kpop Korean
pop groups have offset losses from
piracy with glossy premium collectible
CDs usually sold to fans who will never
play them instead CDs are sold as merch
often with different covers to encourage
buying several and sometimes act as
lottery tickets for a chance to meet
your favorite singer what's so
interesting about kpop as a business is
that almost everything from the very
beginning is manufactured as a consumer
product artists aren't found but created
sculpted for maximum reach over many
years in a factory system and their
international success is no accident
kpop is a deliberate government-funded
project aimed at growing South Korea's
global power making it in the process
highly political
the 1988 Summer Olympics was a turning
point for South Korea like Japan's 1964
and China's 2008 games it was a rare
historic opportunity to change the
country's image abroad harsh censorship
laws and restrictive TV network
monopolies soon opened up giving way to
a new generation of artists four years
later in 1992 the Korean government's
Culture and Tourism Institute began
looking for new overseas markets but
rather than waiting for demand Korean
entertainment hooked foreign viewers and
created it the Institute translated a
popular drama called what is love into
Cantonese which it sent to the Korean
consulate in Hong Kong where it was
offered free to a local TV station soon
Hong Kong and its neighbour Huang Jo
were asking for more not long after that
demand spread to Taiwan Vietnam Japan
and further into mainland China which
established diplomatic relations with
South Korea that same year the media
called this mass cultural dispersion how
you or the Korean Wave the next turning
point came after the 1997 Asian
financial crisis when manufacturing
industries across South and Southeast
Asia saw huge losses in response
President Kim dae-jung turned to the
entertainment sector hiring a PR firm to
launch a new national image the cultural
budget increased 600 percent and a new
Ministry of Culture was formed including
an entire k-pop department the second
Korean Wave came in 2012 with the
explosive viral hit Gangnam style
overnight the whole world became curious
about Korean music dramas fashion and
language and while it wasn't truly
representative of kpop as a genre it was
useful for one big thing proving a song
didn't need to be written in English to
succeed in the West later confirmed by
hits like des passeth though no one
could have predicted the success of
Gangnam style but the rise of Korean
entertainment in some form was
inevitable engineered for in fact by the
kpop formula the difference between its
and other genres is that kpop is reverse
engineered based on consumer preferences
where most musicians start off
practicing in their parents
driven only by a passion for the art and
eventually get discovered by a record
label k-pop groups usually begin rise
and change directions from a conference
room there are four big labels yg SM JYP
and big HIT Entertainment although again
the words label is slightly deceiving
these companies aren't so much agents as
product designers they create and shape
every aspect of their groups first they
begin with recruitment because k-pop
singers are as much public idols as
musicians the composition of
personalities is very important
companies look for a set of distinct yet
cohesive personalities so as to appeal
to his larger fan base as possible while
not generating unnecessary internal
conflict some labels turn recruitment
into a reality TV competition ideal for
creating fan loyalty and dramatizing
personalities in 2012 four percent of
the entire South Korean population tried
out for superstar K its most popular
singing competition other companies
recruit based only on qualities like
appearance because the next component is
training potential stars sometimes as
young as 11 years old go through roughly
5 to 10 years of arduous preparation a
training schedule might be as follows 5
a.m. wake-up practice choreography go to
school get out at 3 p.m.
practice vocals until 6 language lessons
until 9:00 and then exercise until 11:00
leaving an hour to get home before the
train shut down for the night in Seoul
and 5 hours for sleep still after all
that after sacrificing all other hobbies
and dreams after learning English or
Japanese only about 10 percent of
trainees will ever debut k-pop stars
complain of long miserable hours low pay
and unfair 7 year contracts which
include clauses forbidding them from
talking publicly about relationships and
or requiring they maintain a certain
weight labels in turn argue these
stipulations are necessary given the
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
or even millions of dollars and years
they invest in each trainee the third
ingredients and perhaps most important
is localization because kpop
is so diverse incorporating everything
pop to techno rock and hip-hop it's hard
to define what exactly it is one of the
few unifying characteristics which sets
it apart from say Japanese pop is the
way it caters to an international
audience group names generally consist
of a short easily recognized English
word or acronym twice BTS XO or AOA
another common strategy is to have at
least one Chinese Japanese Thai or
Taiwanese group member songs and their
extravagant music videos are often
produced two or three times in Korean
Japanese and Mandarin with English words
sprinkled throughout in addition to
being hugely profitable this
international focus provides Seoul with
something even more valuable
although intangible while soft power
can't be precisely measured it tells a
nation's story in a way no amount of
tanks or factories ever can kpop is so
political because it paints such a vivid
national image thus why South Korea
brought the girl group red velvet to
sing for Kim Jong moon in Pyongyang last
year separately in 2016 the u.s. began
deploying a defense system in South
Korea against potential North Korean
missiles called the terminal high
altitude area defense soon after South
Korean products began disappearing from
Chinese shelves although never
explicitly announced China's government
effectively banned kpop tour groups who
were forbidden from traveling to the
south and previously welcomed k-pop
groups suddenly found their performances
canceled or visas denied music videos
were even blocked from the internet as
groups turned to Hong Kong and Macau
concerts until the ban was relaxed in
2017 it's another example of China using
its large consumer market as leverage
not unlike the recent NBA controversy
both proving the unwavering fortitude of
Chinese patriotism stronger even than
the support of a Kobe Bryant or BTS
superfan finally the last step is to
sell every millimeter of unused space
extreme fan loyalty translates into
extremely effective paid endorsements
product placements and sponsorships the
quintessential example of the formulas
success is the seven member boyband
bTW
their Twitter account generates four
times the engagement of President Donald
Trump's they appeared on The Ellen Show
gave a speech at the United Nations and
contribute an estimated 3.6 billion u.s.
dollars a year to the Korean economy one
study estimates the country gets five
dollars back for every $1 it spends on
kpop it's now building an entire themed
district in the capital with a concert
hall recording studios museum and k-star
Road similar to Hong Kong's Avenue of
the stars or Hollywood's Walk of Fame
some say kpop is too commercialized too
scripted to fake but while some artists
invent touching origin stories kpop is
honest about its motives profits like
professional wrestling yes it's
exaggerated and mass-produced and yes
its fans are aware but there's something
respectably authentic about how
transparently manufactured it all is
it's may be fake but very real is the
joy it brings millions of fans around
the world behind every great k-pop idol
is an intense motivation and need to
learn new skills if you want to learn
how to be more productive or make videos
like these or super meta learn how to
learn faster Skillshare is for you
personally my favorite is youtuber
Thomas Frank's course on staying
organized and getting things done on his
suggestion I started taking Friday's to
review the week and catch up on my to
Do's it's a little thing but has the big
effect of making me feel on top of
things for the rest of the week these
are really well produced high quality
courses and they can be all yours for
less than $10 a month but if you use my
link in the description you'll get two
months to try it yourself completely
free thanks to Skillshare for sponsoring
this video and to you for watching